on va on va passertenant aux invités du
soir on va recevoir dans un instant
clair c'est une jeune femme de 27 ans
qui a subi l'horreur il y a quelques
jours seulement en plein
Paris elle va vous raconter cette
histoire claire sera avec nous et Michel
Marie sera là également puisque il y a
eu deux drames G on va en parler et vous
allez voir cette histoire effroyable
c'est
parti samedi dernier de jeunes femmes
affirment avoir vécu
l'horreur un homme visé par une qtf mise
en examen pour de viols après s'en être
pris à une première femme un SDF aurait
violé quelques instants plus tard une
autre personne âgée de 27 ans dans les
parties communes d'un immeuble une jeune
femme qui déclare avoir été étranglée et
plaquée au sol lors de son agression de
nationalité centrafricaine l'homme qui a
été placé en détention provisoire était
sous le coup d'une obligation de quitter
le territoire français agressé étranglé
samedi dans un hall d'immeuble par un
sans-abri sous qtf claire témoigne ce
soir dans TPMP
je voudrais remercier claire d'être avec
nous merci Claire vousz merci d'être là
ce soir et merci Michel Bari bien
entendu d'être là juste avant qu'on ait
les les les témoignages c'était un
individu donc sous auqtf on va rappeler
ce que c'est l'obligation de quitter le
territoire français qui est une décision
qui est très peu appliquée puisque 7 %
seulement de ces obligations sont
suivies des faits voilà 93 % ne servent
à rien VO pourquoi alors parce que là il
y voà il y a le laxisme total il y a des
problèmes administratifs alors non ce
que nous dit aussi le ministre de
l'intérieur c'est que pay pay j'allais
venir c'est a des pays qui ne veulent
plus l'Algérie pendant très longtemps ne
voulait plus par exemple récupérer ses
ressortissants il y a aussi le fait que
quand les gens sont dans les centres de
rétention ils peuvent faire appel
contreappel il y a des associations il y
a des associations qui leur expliquent
comment en sortir comment débarquer de
l'avion quand ils sont dans l'avion donc
il y a plein de faits plein de facteurs
qui expliquent que les TF en France ne
servent à rien non mais c'est ça donc 7
% c'est incroyable c'est c'est c'est
c'est un taux sidérant c'estàd qu'on en
parle beaucoup mais ces gens-là ils sont
là en permanence et comme ils n'ont
souvent pas de papier et bien ils aent
dans les rues et ils peuvent commettre
des agressions il faut le reconnaître
oui il faut le reconnaîtreou la première
fois puison a c'est pas la première fois
il y en a plein il y a il y a plein
d'exemples de de d'agression comme ça et
souvenons-nous par exemple dabiabé vous
vous souvenez daabab ce meurtre horrible
voilà de la petite
lol euh récemment gare du Nord l'homme
qui blesse des passants à l'arme blanche
au qtf donc il y a plein de ces gens
sous au qtf qui svissent qui continuent
à servévir et à commettre des crimes
monstrueux alors on va voir le
témoignage de Claire dans un instant
juste Michel Marie parce que Claire n'a
pas été la seule ce jour-là à vivre un
enfer
euh l'individu il est il était donc
comme on l'a dit sous qtf alors oui il
était sous qtf les faits se sont
déroulés en en en 3 temps enfin en 2
temps euh puis un troème temps qui est
le temps de l'interpellation ça se
déroule les fesses se déroulent samedi
samedi 11 novembre euh vers 16h une
jeune femme de 19 ans qui est babyiteur
qui allait prendre qui se rendait à son
travail donc dans la famille où elle
devait garder des enfants et elle a été
suivie par un individu elle est rentrée
dans le hall de l'immeuble et l'individu
lui a sauté dessus et la
violé et euh 1h et demi 1 heure et dem
plus tard on saura par la suite que
c'est le même individu s'en est pris
cette fois-ci dans le 8e arrondissement
à une jeune fille de 29 ans qui est
assise à côté de moi
et à qui il a fait subir le même
sort il a ensuite été interpellé par la
sécurité publique dans le 8e
arrondissement c'est sur l'avenue des
Champs-Élysées les deux victimes ont eu
le temps de voir l'agresseur de euh
pouvoir faire une description et à la
fois vestimentaire et physique de cet
individu ça a circulé sur les ones de
police et il y a des fonctionnaires de
police qui se trouvaient sur l'avenue
des Champs-Élysées qui ont repéré un
type qui correspondait à ce signalement
ils l'ont interpellé et c'était le le
bon individu il a été placé en garde à
vue des des féré mis en examen pour viol
aggravé
euh sous la menace d'une arme et il a
été incarcéré alors effectivement il
était sous auqtf et j'écoutais ce que
disait Gill Verdes tout à l'heure mais
c'est vrai que c'est c'est une équation
impossible au qtf parce que on a des
accords avec Bruxelles c'est qu'on est
sous la coupe de Bruxelles et on ne peut
pas en fait sauf à ce que le pays
effectivement soit d'accord pour euh
accueillir le le le ressortissant il se
précipit pas pour les accueillir et ça
prend un temps fou parce que le grand
jeu de ces de ces individus c'est de
dire quand ils sont marocains qui sont
tunisiens quand ils sont tunisiens
d'être algérien et ainsi de suite ce qui
fait que entre les
administrations les les empreintes
digitales où l'ADN circule ça met des
mois et des mois avant de revenir et en
attendant ils sont effectivement placés
dans les centres de rétension mais c'est
à une durée très limitée ensuite on les
remet dehors oui et au bout d'un an f
est caduc au bout d'un an je préciserai
simplement là par rapport à à ces faites
Sam que l'individu repère ses proies il
y a deux fois la présence d'une arme
blanche et des méthodes ex il y a le
viol et une violence terrible puisqu'il
étrangle il plaque au sol donc c'est
quelqu'un d'extrêmement dangereux dont
la dangerosité a été repéré
immédiatement par les policiers qui
l'ont arrêté alors claire est avec nous
merci Claire d'être là merci encore ce
qui vous est arrivé samedi dernier c'est
c'est l'horreur absolue c'était en en
après-midi vous étiez partis faire des
courses vousé dans dans Paris exactement
j'étais parti faire des courses je
devais faire un dîner avec mon copain
justement donc j'étais juste parti
acheter ce que je devais justement
cuisiner et cetera et en fait ce qui
s'est passé c'est que je suis rentrée
j'étais au Monoprix dans le 17e donc à
10 minutes à pied de chez moi qui est
aussi entre l'agression qui sétait passé
juste avant marcher seul tranquille
marcher seul tranquille j'avais même pas
mes écouteurs et en fait juste j'ai
ouvert mon hall de chez moi alors est-ce
que vous sentiez suivi pas du tout pas
du tout pas du tout j'ai rien entendu
vraiment rien du tout vous sentez pas du
tout suivi vous revenez des courses vous
avez des courses vous avez des paquets
dans j'avais juste un petit sac Monoprix
et une bouteille de vin d'accord donc
vous aviez un petit dîner vous préparez
un petit dîner donc on est dans le 8e
arrondissement de Paris qui est assez
fréquenté en plus avec beaucoup de
passages c'est ça qui est exactement il
y a énormément de monde énormément de
monde dans dans les rues dans après ma
rue est assez calme donc comme c'était
le 11 novembre aussi peut-être que les
personnes étaient partis en weekend mais
je pense que enfin oui donc là vous vous
vous sentez rien de de de particulier
vous rentrez donc dans dans dans votre h
d'immeuble vous faites un code vous avez
un code ou bien oui justement enfin j'ai
fait le code et juste la porte est très
très lourde à ouvrir et se referme très
lentement d'accord et j'étais en train
de marcher et j'ai senti quelque chose
qui m'a fait plaquer au sol ah donc en
fait vous rentrez et vous sentez tout de
suite que vous êtes plaqué au sol
exactement et là je me fais enfin
attraper justement et couper la
respiration donc
je comprends pas trop ce qui se passe au
début et après pendant 10 minutes
vraiment je me débats je crie personne
m'entend alors vous êtes là vous êtes
dans le H d'immeuble vous sentez donc
quelqu'un vous arrivez à à vous
retourner vous voyez la la personne pas
du tout parce que enfin cé une personne
quand même qui était assez forte je
pense qu'il faisait au moins 1,85 assez
costaud et avec une capuche en plus donc
j'ai rien vu au début et qui vraiment
m'agrippé le visage comme ça et il vous
a agrpé le visage il vous étrangle il
m'étrangle il m'étouffe il me coupe la
respiration aussi donc il vous vous êtes
à terre à terre du coup oui il était
au-dessus de moi vous vous essayez de
crier vous arrivez à crier quand même ou
pas au début j'arrive à crier sauf que
je vois que je m'étouffe entre
guillemets de plus en plus donc juste je
me dis que c'est un peu compliqué et
puis en plus il me fait des menaces de
mort qu'est-ce qu'il vous dit il me dit
je vais te tuer chute tais-toi je vais
te
tuer il vous dit ce qui ce qu' ve ce
qu'il veut tout de suite ou pas du tout
au début non pensez à quoi au début
pense à quoi estce que là là je me dis
vous vous rentr de course vous vous
retrouvez plaqué au sol agressé vous
pensez à quoi ce momentl vous dites
c'est quoi vous dites c'est il veut quoi
au début je me dis qu'il veut juste me
enfin me voler entre guillemets et que
bah il va juste prendre mon sac et mon
téléphone et que enfin ça sen finira et
en fait au final il commence à me dire
que il veut plus il vous dit quoi il me
dit tu vas faire ce que je te dis
maintenant et tu vas arrêter de crier
et du coup enfin je vais te
baiser
euh là bien sûr vous on va pas rentrer
dans les détails bien sûr bien sûr
euh qu'est-ce qui donc là il il a il
arrive ass ses fin bah du coup en fait
j'essaie de me débattre pendant une
dizaine de minutes je vois que c'est un
peu peine perdu et que pour sauver ma
peau le seul moyen c'était que justement
je fasse ce qu'ils veulent donc
justement enfin pendant 20 minutes après
il y a eu il y a eu viol et pendant ce
temps-là en fait je me suis un peu
dissocié de mon c et je me suis dit il
faut que je trouve toutes les solutions
possibles pour pouvoir en tout cas
partir et enin juste quitter cet endroit
quoi c'est cauchemar il dure 20 minutes
30 minutes 30 minutes mais personne ne
rentre et ne sort de l'immeuble non et
là vous voyez ça fait que 10 minutes
qu'on se parle et c'est toujours pas
fini le vool non non mais je vous jure
c'est c'est c'est incroyable personne
personne ne rentre ni ne sort de
l'immeuble pendant ces 30 minutes non
vous vous vous criez plus moment vous
vous je crie plus parce que je sais que
enfin je sais pas pourquoi je sentais
qu'il avait peut-être une une arme sur
lui j'ai entendu des bruits un peu de
métal et je me suis juste dit ok bah
sauve ta peau et en attendant qu' a
quelqu'un qui arrive fait ce qu'il dit
vous aviez peur de de de le de de le
frapper de de de lui de le voilà de de
trop crier un moment vous êtes dit ça va
être pire exactement je me suis dit que
juste il fallait mieux rien dire il
était où il était où votre copain à ce
moment-là euh bah il était chez lui il
était sensé arriver l'heure d'après quoi
et donc là ce qui est fou je vous dis
c'est incroyable pendant une demi-heure
personne qui rentre dans le dans dans
dans le hall de
l'immeuble qu'est-ce que vous vous dites
à ce momentl vous dites la seule manière
de m'en sortir c'est quoi parce que
est-ce que vous vous vous dites je vais
il va me tuer ou est-ce que vous dites
non c'est je vais faire ce qu'il me dit
et peut-être qu'il va partir après non
je pensais que après qu'il a eu ses
faims aussi enfin qu' littéralement me
tue donc je me suis dit qu'en fait
j'allais attendre le moment où il il
était capable de entre guillemets lâcher
prise pr pour pouvoir justement partir
et m'échapper alors justement qu'est-ce
qu'est-ce qui se passe parce que
comment qu'est-ce qu'il vous dit quand
quand il s'en va qu'est-ce qu'il vous
dit comment quand vous sentez que bon il
va il va partir et que vous allez
survivre à ce à ce drame euh du coup en
fait il y a une il y a une voisine qui
descend de l'immeuble et qui ouvre la
porte et qui nous voit et moi en fait le
moment où il tourne la tête je savais
très bien où était mon sac et mon
téléphone et je me suis dit j'ai besoin
de mon téléphone pour appeler la police
j'ai besoin de mon sac pour rentrer chez
moi donc je cours vers mon sac et mon
téléphone pour les récupérer et juste je
vais derrière la voisine et lui à ce
moment-là part prend la
fuite là là vous êtes dans quel état à
ce momentl avec la voisine avec bah dans
un état j'avais plein de sang sur moi
aussi parce que du coup j'avais une
bouteille de vin qui s'est éclaté par
terre donc j'ai essayé de me débattre
d'où le le pement là où j'ai dû me faire
opérer et cetera après en plus euh et en
fait ce qui s'est passé juste bah j'ai
commencé à dire à la voisine que je me
faisais violer je pleurais excusezmi
parce qu'ona pas entendu pardon juseque
enfin je me faisais violer du coup et au
début elle comprenait pas et en fait le
seul enfin son seul objectif c'était de
prendre son uber pour partir en voyage
quoi elle vous dit quoi la voisine par
que c'est incroyable ça aussi écoutez
vous lui dites je viens de me faire
violer vous êtes dans un état vous
saignez vous êtes dans un état de de de
forcément de de
de de choc incroyable et elle vous dit
quoi elle vous prend pour une foute elle
lui a dit quoi au début elle croyais que
c'était juste une scène d'amour ah ouais
et j'étais là M non vous voyaz bien que
enfin je suis à moitié nu enfin c'est ça
va pas du tout en fait je commence à
pleurer et du coup elle me donne juste
son numéro pour entre guillemets que je
l'appelle après elle a été vraiment enin
sur son uber et elle voulait absolument
prendre son uber donc elle m'a juste
laissé son numéro elle m'a dit de
prendre de la vitamine D aussi et
aprèsiableou mais est-ce que est-ce que
vous avez vu l'individu à un moment
est-ce que vous avez pu le voir
ressemblait à quoi donc des grand bon
parce que maintenant il a été arrêté
mais est-ce que vous avez pu voir son
visage à un moment ou pas du tout
justement j'ai fait en sorte d'analyser
tout pour pouvoir repérer le plus
d'éléments possible et oui j'ai analysé
qu'il avait une griffure sur le visage
et que enfin il mesurait tant de temps
de maître corpulence et cetera les
vêtements c'estàdire que quand vous
viviez ce cauchemar vous pensiez à tout
ça vous dites il faut que j'ai plus
d'éléments possible pour pouvoir ensuite
qu'on puisse appréhender ce ce cet
individu exactement en plus il avait dit
que il me disait des choses comme quoi
j'allais rien dire à personne et que
j'allais me taire sinon ça all être
encore plus grave après donc euh ensuite
euh qu'est-ce qui se passe après parce
que
euh les minutes sont des heures
forcément au bout de 30 minutes euh donc
votre agresseur part euh bien sûr vous
êtes vous êtes soulagé mais à quoi vous
pensez à ce
moment-là je me dis ouf déjà d'accord et
premier réflexe c'est euh enfin du coup
la voisine qui me laisse comme ça donc
là vous vous retrouvez seul dans le rle
seul et puis en fait je rentre dans mon
appartement du coup ouais et je
m'enferme à double tour et premier
réflexe j'appelle mon copain pour qu'il
vienne le plus rapidement possible quoi
votre copain par que là vous faites vous
vous êtes quoi vous l'appelez vous êtes
dans quel état vous vous criez vous lui
dites il m'est arrivé une horreur juste
il m' arrivé quelque chose de très grave
vient tout de suite je viens de me faire
violer quoi et agresser il vous dis quoi
il me dit ok j'arrive mais il comprend
pas
et là quand il arrive vous il vous
trouve bah en attendant enfin j'avais
déjà appelé la police et cetera qui
était déjà sur place donc le temps qu'il
arrive enfin c'est déjà bien encadré et
cetera mais ouais donc vous appelez la
police j'appelle la police qui arrive
dans les 10 minutes qui suivent donc
franchement la police a été incroyable
encore et ils l'ont interpellé très vite
après d'ailleurs aussi exactement et
donc la police vous faire quoi police
très bien encadré ça ça a duré plus de
72 heures entre retour chez les médecins
les tests et cetera chez l'UMJ en même
même temps la police judiciaire la
déposition et cetera mais non ils ont
vraiment été très forts là-dessus et en
plus comme ils ont comme ils l'ont
retrouvé enfin juste parfait vous êtes
donc opéré le lendemain parce que vous
êtes débattu vous êtes blessé au doigts
à cause de votre votre bouteille de vin
aujourd'hui on est 5 jours après ce
terrible
drame vous êtes dans quel état parce
qu'on on trouve que vous je trouve que
vous êtes très très fort vraiment que
vous arrivez à en parler avec un
détachement incroyable tout à l'heure
vous n avez dit en fait j'ai essayé de
sortir de mon corps est-ce que vous
réalisez après 5 jours ou pas encore je
pense pas encore c'est ça parce que je
sais que c'est un peu mon inconscient
qui parle parce que il parle que quand
je dors et là je fais des cauchemars et
cetera mais sinon dans la vraie vie je
suis forte je pleur pas vous n'arrivez
plus à dormir non enfin je suis obligé
de prendre les somnifères
donc vous pensez à quoi enfin vous rêvez
de quoi vous cauchemarz de quoi vous
revoyez le le visage de de C l'agresseur
ou pas du euh le visage oui et puis
surtout enfin l'agressement et enfin le
fait que je suis en train d'étouffer et
de me faire tuer euh vous sortez plus
seul j'imagine non j'ai beaucoup de mal
voilà aujourd'hui quoi vous regardez
tout le temps derrière vous vous êtes
tout le temps j'appelle tout le temps
des gens quand je suis dehors je peux
pas rentrer toute seule chez moi je peux
pas rester plus d'une heure toute seule
non plus sinon enfin je commence à
repenser à ce qui s'est
passé avec votre copain quand il il
habite il habite chez vous désormais
pour le moment oui temporairement du
coup parce que un peu compliqué comment
il a trouvé les mots aussi parce que
c'est il vous a dit quoi il m'a vraiment
beaucoup rassuré et il a vraiment été là
pour moi de A à Z il m'a accompagné à
tous les rendez-vous et cetera mais enin
après il y a pas grandchose à dire non
plus c'est fait c'est fait et on y est
pour rien et c'est comme ça le lendemain
vous apprenez dans la presse que votre
agresseur n'aurait pas dû être là h
puisqu'il était sous au qtf obligation
de de quitter le territoire
français comment vous réagissez est-ce
que ça vous énerve encore plus oui
forcément ça m'énerve après je pense que
un viol c'est pas forcément que un cttf
ça peut être n'importe qui mais c'est
vrai que ça rajoute une colère en plus
en sachant que bah il était censé
quitter le territoire et aujourd'hui bah
il a plutôt enfin violé le territoire
entre guillemets donc enfin c'est assez
énervant et je me dis que c'est je suis
pas la première et que il faudrait avoir
vraiment des mesures un peu plus
radicales pour pouvoir et il vous
parleit beaucoup il il un petit peu oui
il m'a demandé aussi de pouvoir rentrer
chez moi ah ouais donc j'aurais pu me
faire séquestrer aussi s'il avait
regardé un petit peu dans mon sac les
clés et cetera et mon plus vous lui
disiez quoi quand vous quand il vous a
dit je veux rentrer chez toi je disais
en non j'ai mes parents qui habitent
chez moi c'est pas possible TR bien
ouais vous avez vous avez réussi à quand
même à à garder une lucidité pour
pouvoir répondre des des des choses qui
puissent peut-être vous sauver la vie h
vous avez pensé qu'à ça à sauver votre
vie à ce moment-là exactement euh clair
je je je crois que vous voulez dire
aussi un mot sur sur les viols parce que
qui sont trop souvent banalisés certains
dit associe uniquement le viol à la à la
pénétration vous aujourd'hui qu'est-ce
que vous aimeriez dire parce que votre
histoire voilà elle a glacé tout le
monde c'est un témoignage très important
parce qu'on on veut pas que ça se
reproduise et vous aussi vous voulez pas
que ça se reproduise et c'est très
courageux de voir votre part clair
d'être là ce soir qu'est-ce que vous
vouliez dire je veux juste dire que en
fait le viol enfin pour recontextualiser
c'est un un acte non consenti
pénétration que ça soit prénétration
orale ou juste digitale et euh juste que
en fait même une main baladeuse c'est
aussi ça peut être considéré aussi comme
un viol et que enfin faut un peu se
remettre en question euh les hommes ils
sont pas permis de tout et les hommes
aussi peuvent enfin ou les femmes entre
guillemets tout le monde enfin peut
réaliser un viol eTTH juste il y a
beaucoup de femmes qui n'en parlent pas
aujourd'hui et c'est pour ça aussi que
je prends la parole aujourd'hui parce
que j'ai envie de parler pour les femmes
et de leur dire que juste enfin il faut
en parler il y a des numéros il y a des
associations et juste pourou voir se
libérer vous allez pensez que vous allez
pouvoir revivre normalement ou vous êtes
inquiète de ça non forcément je suis
inquiète ouais euh après je pense que il
faut démocratiser la chose et je vais
essayer au maximum d'en parler pour
pouvoir me libérer aussi ça vous fait du
bien d'en parler bien sûr vous y pensez
tout le temps bah c'est un peu le sujet
d'actualité tous les jours ouais donc
j'essaye 5 jours après euh est-ce que
vous avez pour vous euh déjà évolué
est-ce que vous avez déjà euh voilà
évoluer dans votre vie tous les jours ou
est-ce que vous êtes toujours dans le
dans le même état ou est-ce que vous
dites pas peut-être que je vais avoir
une très grosse redescente dans dans
dans quelques jours mais je pense qu'en
fait le viol c'est pendant l'acte et
c'est aussi après l'acte et euh
apparemment c'est le plus dur après même
6 mois après c'est encore pire parce
qu'on se sent de plus en plus seul il y
a beaucoup moins de gens qui nous
entourent aussi les gens autour oublient
sûr ouais et euh bah moi j'espère que ça
va aller mieux mais c'est vrai que vous
voulez à qui
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui en soit enfin peut-être à la
justice qui a pas fait son travail pour
ça en tout cas à l'état aussi parce
qu'il aurait dû être envoyé après enfin
est-ce que je peux en vooir à quelqu'un
particulièrement oui à l'agresseur
sûrement bien sûr quand vous avez appris
qu'il avait été arrêté vous avez été
soulagé bien sûr heureusement vent ouais
vous avez vous êtes dit fait quoi oui et
puis en plus on se sent pas forcément
enfin je me sens moins seulle parce que
du coup la fille qui était avant moi
aussi enfin a vécu la même chose vous
êtes parlé oui on s'est parlé et euh
c'est important ça aussi très important
parce qu'on sent Souda du coup donc
exactement merci d'avoir été avec nous
CLA merci pour ce témoignage cont merci
à tous merci tout de suite il y a que la
vérité
qui